This is Katie can trial with factory
farming awareness coalition. She,
she's here to speak today about the
impacts of an animal agriculture on the
environment. Um, and so I hope
everybody enjoys the presentation.
Okay,
so he was kidding.
Thank you so much and thank you
everyone for coming. So again,
my name is Katie [inaudible].
I'm the founder and executive director
of the factory farming awareness
coalition or a local nonprofit based
in the bay area dedicated to talking to
people about the impacts
of our food choices.
Here's an outline of what
we'll be discussing today,
the basics of factory farming,
what that term means,
an overview of the environmental impacts
and we'll conclude by talking about
potential solutions.
So you know,
while some of this information
is disturbing and depressing,
I promised that we will end on an upbeat
note and there'll be little cuteness
interludes in between each section to
give you a chance to ask questions. Now,
how many of you are saying
all Mcdonald's when your kids,
or maybe you're singing
it with your own children?
So when we walk into the supermarket
and look around a picture,
pictures on products, it looks like old
MacDonald's farm is still around today.
We see all these rolling green
hills sides, all those happy cows.
But unfortunately,
this is not what farming is like anymore
in the United States rather than old
Mcdonald.
This is what we have today.
Factory farms are technically known as
concentrated animal feeding operations or
k foes. It's a practice of keeping
thousands, tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands of animals in
confinement for their entire lives.
This has done to produce the
most product for the most profit.
Before we go any further,
does anyone want to guess how many
animals are Brad and killed for food every
year in the United States?
You don't already know the answer.
Anyone want to take a guess?
Okay, so pretty close.
So yeah,
there's actually 9 billion there.
Between nine and 10 billion animals raised
and killed for food every single year
in the United States alone. This is just
land animals, not even counting fish.
So there are more farmed animals in the
United States than there are people on
the entire planet. Now. Of
these 9 billion animals,
what percentage of them do you think are
raised on factory farms rather than on
this nice small old Mcdonald type farms?
80% but 99% some 99% of meat that
you see nowadays in restaurants or
supermarkets is going to be
coming from these factory farms.
Now if we've heard the
term factory farming,
it's usually in the context of animal
welfare and that's not what we'll be
focusing on today.
But I do briefly want to discuss what
conditions look like on factory farms
because that's also what contributes to
most of the environmental problems as
well. And I think it helps to understand
the mindset of factory farming,
which is really summed up best
by national hog farmer magazine.
They said the breeding sow,
which is a mother pig,
should be thought of and treated as a
valuable piece of machinery whose function
is to pump out baby pigs
like a sausage machine.
So these are no longer thought of as
living and creatures they're thought of as
units of production.
It is this mindset that allows us to
treat farmed animals in ways that we would
never dream of treating our dogs or cats.
So again,
the hallmark of factory farming is this
intensive confinement the animal spend
their entire lives sometimes can find in
Kate's or courageous CZ cages or crates
so small that they cannot even turn
around other industries like the Turkey
industry, they're kept by the
thousands inside of these sheds.
So this obviously causes extreme
problems for animal offer.
They can't engage in even the
most basic of natural behaviors,
but it is also this overcrowding that
causes the environmental issues as well.
So for the rest of the presentation,
you have to keep in mind that these are
what conditions look like on factory
farms where 99% in meat is coming from.
Now.
One question that frequently comes up
is what about the labels that we see on
products that seemed to indicate
they're coming from better places?
So I want to quickly go through what
those mean. I'll start with cage free.
This is a picture of a cage free egg farm.
Now it's true.
These hands aren't in cages,
but it's not exactly what we imagine
when we see the term cage free.
He says happy looking chickens
on the front of the carton,
so it really means just
that they're not in cages,
but they're still kept by the tens of
thousands inside of these industrial sheds
for their entire lives.
Unfortunately,
conditions on free range
farms are very similar,
so technically it means the animals
must have access to the outdoors,
but there are no real enforced
specifications for what that means,
and there are a lot of loopholes as well
that lot farms get away with keeping
their animals can find by the tens
of thousands inside of these sheds.
But if there's access to the outdoors
like a tiny little door that opens onto a
dirt patch,
it can technically count as free range
even if not a single animal ever actually
steps foot outside.
Now to give you a real world example,
the wording on the left is
from a package of Judy's eggs,
which is a popular organic free range
brand from right here in northern
California.
It says these hands are raised in wide
open spaces and Sonoma valley where they
are free to roam,
scratch and play.
While on the right you can see an aerial
photo of what Judy's farm actually
looks like. Those are those industrial
sheds with tens of thousands of chickens.
There aren't any birds outside and
the purple that you see in front,
there is a manure pit, which we will be
talking about much more in a few minutes.
Now, Judy is actually settled a lawsuit
with the Animal Legal Defense Fund for
misleading consumers with the
claims on their packaging.
So they have changed the wording,
but there are still certified free range
and organic and in fact they rebrand
under several different brand names,
which is a very common practice to make
consumers think they're coming from
these nice little individual family
farms when they're coming from the same
source,
these factory farms,
so they sell under Judy's Uncle
Daddy's rock island gold circle.
There are also a leading
supplier for whole foods,
three 65 brand and organic valley.
So unfortunately even some of the most
respected organic free range brands are
in fact sourcing from factory farms.
The final term that you might see is
humane and this has no legal meaning
whatsoever. The USDA does
not regulate the term humane,
nor do they the term natural, so any
company can put these on any product.
It's really just a marketing gimmick
and it's unfortunate because these
companies are taking advantage of
consumers desire to buy products that are
coming from a better place.
We don't want animals to be mistreated.
We don't want to impact the
environment and negative ways.
But unfortunately this is usually just
used as a mechanism to increase the price
when they are,
they're still coming from factory farms.
Animal Agriculture is one of the single
most destructive industries on the
planet.
I know this can seem a little bizarre
for still imagining old MacDonald's farm.
What could be so bad about,
oh, Mcdonald's, right?
So I'm going to walk you through it.
So again,
keep in mind that there are 9 billion
animals raised and killed for food every
year. And this is where most of the
environmental problems stem from.
It's the sheer number of animals that
are required to make enough meat for 300
million plus Americans to eat meat
every single day. Often with every meal.
And the problems come from the fact that
these are 9 billion living, breathing,
eating, pooping animals. Now they're
eating primarily corn and soy.
And we imagine farmers and farm land
in the U S we, I think, imagine, um,
we imagine growing crops to feed to
people, right? But in the United States,
over half of all farmland is planted with
corn and soy and most of that is going
to feed not people,
but two animals on factory farms.
This is a problem for
several different reasons.
One is that animals are actually
a very inefficient source of food.
So imagine that you are raising an animal
for food from the day that that animal
is born until the day that you
slaughter it, you have to feed it right.
So that's days, weeks, months,
potentially even years that you're
giving this animal food every single day.
So if you add up all of the food that you
give to that animal over the course of
its lifetime,
it ends up being anywhere from two to 15
times more food than the amount of food
that you get from eating
that animal's flesh.
The latest studies have found that if
we cut global meat consumption in half,
and we used all of that farmland to grow
fruits and veggies for people to eat
directly,
rather than growing that corn and soy
to feed to animals on factory farms,
we could feed every single
person on earth. Today plus
an extra 2 billion people.
So we hear a lot of talk about how are
we going to feed the growing global
population.
And in fact we could do it easily if we
were using our land more efficiently,
but eating lower on the food chain,
this land use is a huge
problem globally as well.
Me Production is actually the leading
cause of the Amazon rain forest being cut
down. We can see that here in this
infographic from the center for biological
diversity.
Every minute there are two acres of
rainforest clear cut to make grazing land
for beef cattle or land to grow corn and
soy to feed to animals on factory farms.
This is also a problem in
the United States as well.
Oftentimes people think I don't want to
support factory farms so I'm going to
buy free range beef. Now there are a
couple of different problems with this.
One is that actually most beef cattle
or free range for the first eight to 10
months of their lives. So if you drive,
you know, especially in Moran Petaluma,
that area you might see these bucolic
looking cattle grazing on hillsides.
And it looks very nice,
but most of those cattle are then shipped
to industrial feedlots where they're
fed corn and soy intensively for the
last few months of their lives to fatten
them up to reach market weight.
The other big problem is that while there
are certain ecosystems that do benefit
from having grazing ruminant animals,
there is a limit to how many
animals that land can sustain.
It's called the carrying capacity.
And when you exceed that,
you start to have these very
serious ecological problems.
And that's what we're seeing across the
west now. So cattle are being grazed on,
uh, on public lands. So the government
is basically subsidizing these,
this grass in order to
Gracie's free range cattle.
But the bureau of land management,
which manages this land is not insuring
that it's being managed properly to
prevent these environmental problems.
So you have too many cattle on this land,
so they're eating everything
that comes up out of the ground.
They're eating what would grow into
shrubs and trees to provide habitat for
native animals. This also causes
soil erosion and impacts waterways.
So a lot of different devastating
impacts of overgrazing.
And to make matters worse,
there's a very secretive government
agency called wildlife services.
They're a part of the USTA,
and in 2015 they killed
over 3 million animals,
mostly at the request of ranchers. So
they're killing off predators like wolves,
bears, coyotes. Fox is mountain
lions that could kill the livestock.
They're killing off prairie dogs and
ground squirrels can dig holes that the
cattle could fall into even
rounding up and killing Buffalo.
So native ruminate animals because they're
competing with the cattle for feed.
So we're destroying these entire
native ecosystems in order to make them
suitable for free range cattle.
Now another big problem with all of these
animals and all of these crops is that
they're very water intensive. Now when
we think about ways to save water,
what are some things that come to mind?
What are ways we're told?
Just to say we can help save water.
Yeah, take shorter showers, right?
That's a classic one. Turn off the
tap when you brush your teeth, right?
Water your lawn less.
So all of these suggestions
focus on our direct water usage.
In this next video clip
from the movie Casper, see,
we'll see how this compares to the
water impact of our food choices.
I found out that one quarter
pound hamburger requires
over 660 gallons of water
to produce. Here. I've been
taking these short showers,
trying to save water and to find out just
eating one hamburger is the equivalent
of showering two entire months.
So much attention is given to
lowering our home water use.
Yet domestic water use is only 5% of what
is consumed in the u s versus 55% for
animal agriculture.
That's because it takes upwards of 2,500
gallons of water to produce one pound
of beef.
The single best way that we can help say
water on a daily basis is through our
food choices, so the numbers they
used, they're on the high end,
but even the more conservative estimates
show switching from my hamburger to
Veggie Burger, just one single
time opting for a Veggie Burger.
Instead of a hamburger,
you save as much water as not
showering for one entire month.
So all that water, all of
this, um, corn and soy.
Also a lot of hormones,
pesticides,
antibiotics are fed to these 9 billion
animals. It goes through their system.
And then what happens to food after
we digest it? It comes out as poop.
Farm animals in the United States produce
130 times as much proof as the entire
us human population,
and there's very little waste
infrastructure for factory farms.
One of America's biggest secrets is that
farms practically don't exist anymore.
The animals we eat are grown
inside giant hidden factories.
Since 2012 I've been secretly planning
a project to expose these factory farms
using the highest texts,
spy equipment available
drones.
This video provides just a sample of
what I saw during only a few days of
filming.
You're looking at a lake of toxic 80
CC's and urine the size of four football
fields.
That's because thousands upon thousands
of pigs are inside of these buildings.
Their waste falls through slats in the
concrete floor and it sloshed it directly
into this giant open air cesspool.
How many of these kinds of factories
are there in North Carolina alone?
There are over 2000 and the
consequences are disastrous.
The waste false through through
the floors it's flushed out.
And to have an open pit assess Paul,
it's easy for a big hog operation to
have as much waste as a medium size city.
Of course the pit will fill up so it
has to be empty and they're empty by
spraying the liquid waste.
Yes. You heard that right? Yep.
If you're familiar with a garden sprayer,
they're gigantic versions of that.
So they're making droplets fine mists
out of this liquid waste and that can
drift down wind into the
neighboring communities. Uh,
shut my hog operation down
and I got out of it and uh, I,
I couldn't,
I just couldn't do another person
that way to make them smell bad.
It is a safe food. If you put
please season, you're urinary,
a hole in the ground that
you dump a toxic waste.
And I've seen dead hogs and
stuff like that. People can't
open their windows. They can't
go outside. I've seen it.
I've talked to the people. I've seen the
little children. They say mama data. Wow,
we got to smell
this.
Did you get stories like I
can't hang my clothes out. Pc.
Oda Combine attacking itself to your
clothes and then people are saying we're
spirited by neighbors. It can. I
think we're very correctly, right?
Be called environmental racism
or environmental injustice
that people of color,
low income people bear the
brunt of these practices,
so this is where they spray
around our waist on us.
This is about eight feet
from my mother's house.
What is it like when the mist that snacks,
you think it's raining
really? You think it's raining? We
don't open the doors, the windows,
but the oldest still comes in. It takes
your breath away. Then you start gagging,
you get headaches.
Is there a number of studies
of asthma and asthma symptoms,
particularly in children near
these facilities? Among adults,
there are reports of several types
of upper respiratory symptoms.
These pollutants are affecting
people's blood pressure.
Who's responsible for all
this Smithfield suits,
specifically the subdivision Murphy Brown,
which controls the factory farms shown in
all of the drone footage in this video.
Smithfield is by far the largest
pork producer in the entire world.
And inside these buildings there
is something else entirely.
Pigs are really intelligent animals.
They are more intelligent than dogs.
They are more intelligent than cats.
In the average pig barn,
there could be hundreds,
if not thousands of pigs crammed
into this one sprawling indoor space.
Their entire life has been
standing on concrete floors.
Mother pigs are locked in metal cages
so small that they literally cannot even
turn around for months at a time.
This is not a partisan issue.
We are all opposed to children being
made sick to animals being abused and to
everyday people's lives being ruined
by the stench of cesspools in their
backyards.
These thousands of lakes of toxic waste
must be among the most bizarre and
disturbing environmental phenomenon
that has ever confronted America.
And Dave had been kept well hidden
from the public for long enough.
So you've just seen what happens to all
of this waste. It's fairly shocking,
right? And for urban consumers
meet starts at the supermarket.
It starts at a restaurant.
We don't ever have to see or
experience the real impacts of it,
so it's usually these rural low income
communities, often communities of color,
the bear the brunt of the
rest of our meat consumption.
They're the ones who have to be exposed
to this environmental pollution on a
daily basis.
The other huge problem with all of
these animals and all of this waste is
climate change.
I report from the United Nations
found that animal agriculture creates
greenhouse gas emissions
than all the planes,
trains and cars in the entire
world all added up together.
Part of the reason for this is it
ruminant animals like cows and sheep lambs
actually burp methane,
which is 20 times worse for
climate change and carbon dioxide.
The poop from all of these different
types of animals, chickens, pigs,
all the ones that we've
seen releases nitrous oxide,
which is 300 times worse for
climate change than carbon dioxide.
And they're also all
of the impacts of that.
Deforestation when you consider the
whole life cycle of everything that's
required to produce the meat.
The deforestation also plays a large
role because they're cutting down forest
that would otherwise be absorbing CO2.
So when you factor in all
of these things together,
you see that our food choices are also
the single best way that we can help
shrink our carbon footprint on a daily
basis. Just like our water footprint.
So one study found that not
eating meat just one day a week,
say some more greenhouse gas emissions
and buying local food 100% of the time.
Okay.
A different study found that if everyone
in the United States ate no meat or
cheese,
just one day a week,
it would be like not driving 91 billion
miles are taking 7.6 million cars off
the road.
So we can think about what are the
chances that we're going to convince 7
million people to sell their
cars and never drive again?
Probably not going to happen,
right?
Whereas getting people to not eat
meat just one day a week, you know,
choose a PB and j instead
of a Turkey Sandwich.
And a Veggie burrito
instead of a beef burrito.
It's one of the easiest and most effective
ways that we can help stop climate
change.
Okay.
And in fact there's more and more
scientific evidence showing that we cannot
keep climate change to a level that's
conducive to human civilization without
addressing the carbon
footprint of agriculture.
So this study found that the
agriculture related emissions alone,
if we continue our current practices,
especially as a global population grows
and demand for meat goes up worldwide
than agriculture alone will take up
almost all of the global carbon budget by
2050 so this means that even if we got
every other industry down to carbon
neutral,
but we left agriculture the same,
we would still be hitting
that two degree target.
So the only scenario that would reduce
emissions in 2050 compared to 2009 levels
is what they call the
healthy diets scenario,
which is switching to significantly
more plant based protein
and as an added benefit,
eating more plant based protein also
has positive impacts on the health of
citizens and on health care costs.
So if American's transitioned
to a plant by plant based diet,
not only would it reduce food related
greenhouse gas emissions by 79% we could
also avoid 460,000 deaths and save $289
billion in healthcare costs and climate
change costs.
So one of the reasons that people eat
so much meat is that it seems cheap,
but that's because the
true of it or externalize.
So we don't have to see
the environmental costs,
the healthcare costs when we go to the
store, when we go to the restaurant.
But as taxpayers we are
actually paying the true cost.
And the most effective way to reverse
that is to transition to a more plant
based diet.
The basic solution is very simple.
We have to eat less meat.
That's really what it boils down to.
And different organizations,
world leaders are starting to catch on
to this and starting to encourage people
to switch to plant based protein.
So the United Nations Environmental
Program has urged first world citizens to
cut our meat consumption,
half become what they call dematerial.
The Stockholm International Water
Institute has gone even further.
And said that we need to limit animal
based foods to just 5% of our total daily
calories. Right now the make up about
30% of the standard American diet,
so they said we need to eat just one
sixth as much meat as we currently are,
and they've warned that
if we do not do this,
then we will be faced with food and water
shortages worldwide that could lead to
civil war. So the stakes are
about as high as they get.
When we're talking about things
like climate change, global famine,
and all of this can be impacted
directly through our food choices.
Now a big challenge is how do you get
people interested in eating less meat?
There are a lot of reasons that people
eat meat. It tastes good, it's cheap,
it's convenient, it's part of our
culture, it's part of our habit.
And so now different organizations
and nonprofits as well as money,
different food startups,
especially in the bay area are working
on ways to get people excited about
eating more plant based protein.
One initiative that's been very
successful as meatless Mondays.
This was actually started by Johns
Hopkins University as a public health
initiative as we saw a few slides ago.
Healthcare costs are hugely impacted
by the amount of animal protein than
Americans currently consume. Many of
the leading causes of death, cancer,
heart disease, diabetes, stroke,
are directly related to eating
too much animal protein,
so they figured if people
eat even a seventh less meat,
if people are not eating
meat one day a week,
then it will really help people's
health and many other organizations have
jumped on board and said it's a great way
to help the environment and animals as
well and even for die hard meat lovers.
The idea of not eating meat meat,
just one day a week is something that
seems very doable and currently a third of
Americans report trying to participate.
Green Monday is also another
really successful program,
but it's similar to meatless Monday,
but really focused on those
environmental impacts,
emphasizing the fact that the best way
to go green is by eating more plant based
protein.
It's actually based in Hong Kong and
they've had tremendous success in shifting
the entire cities eating habits by having
a really positive empowering campaign.
Emphasizing that eating green choosing
veggie options is a very effective step
to take. And Green Monday emphasizes that,
you know, it's not a one size fits all.
So oftentimes people are deterred from
taking a step because they think that
they won't be able to be perfectly 100%
vegetarian or Vegan and so get dissuaded
and they give up.
But as a green Monday shows,
there are a number of different
ways that we can go about this.
So whether that's routine based,
one day a week,
so green Monday or meatless Monday,
you can do every day for lunch,
eat a vegetarian or Vegan lunch
it, you know, just one meal a day.
It's pretty doable for most people.
But if you do that,
then a third of the time you'll be eating
fudge. It can also be portioned based.
So decreasing the amount
of meat theory are eating,
increasing the amount
of plant based protein,
vegetarian foods on your plate,
or it can be impact based.
So pledging to only order Veggie burgers
instead of hamburgers from now on.
There are many different ways that we
can play around with our food choices and
increase the amount of plant based
foods that we're eating. And again,
as one of the single most
effective actions that we can take.
There are also some very exciting tech
solutions that are in the works right now,
namely clean meat.
So clean meat involves extracting
stem cells from animal tissue,
culturing those and then basically
growing meat tissue in the lab and then
layering that to produce hamburgers,
chicken nuggets. So it is actually meet,
I mean it is animal tissue and it's
based on medical technology used to grow
human skin cells to
graft onto burn victims,
but they're actually growing
meat and this is successful.
Memphis meats has produced just um,
I think about a month ago they had the
first tastings of clean chicken and duck
meat. And there are a few other companies
that are working on beef as well.
And this is extremely more
efficient than factory farming.
So clean meat uses 99% less land.
96 produces 96% less greenhouse gas
emissions and uses 96% less water.
And there's a really great organization
called the Good Food Institute that is
working to help encourage the science
behind clean meat and policy around clean
meat as well.
So according to the latest estimates,
it should be on the market within
about four to five years. Again,
the technology is there,
it's just a matter of scaling it so that
it's cost competitive with factory farm
meat. But I think this is one
of the most hopeful development.
So if we can replace fast food,
meet with clean meat,
then we will see drastic
impacts on the environment.
And obviously it's for animals as well.
But the good news is that you don't have
to wait four or five years to make a
difference.
There are a number of other startups
all based right around here that are
working on creating foods that have
the same case in textures that we love,
but they are made from more
sustainable plant based sources.
So as Biz stone said, these guys are
coming at the meat analog industry,
not as a novelty. They're coming
at it from the big science angle.
So they're really, these products are
not made for vegetarian markets anymore.
They're not made for niche market.
They're getting the top chefs,
top food scientists to create products
that are really delicious and satisfying
for diehard meat lovers.
So you have companies like
beyond meat and impossible foods,
which makes the Burger,
the burger that bleeds as it's been
getting a lot of attention in the press.
Hampton creek foods,
which makes just male, um,
cookie salad dressings and all of
these products. You can read articles,
see interviews online,
they do blind taste tests and people
can't tell the difference. So,
okay,
if the main reason that we're eating
meat is because it tastes good,
it's fantastic news that there are now
products available that have that same
taste, the same texture, but they're
better for us, better for animals,
better for the environment.
So it's really a win win.
And this is a top growing trend.
This is really the direction that the
market is moving. So food navigator,
magazine, mental, um, business,
uh, the nutrition business journal,
I mean they've all documented that
Americans are eating more and more plant
based foods. They're interested
in it from a health angle,
from an environmental angle.
And this is consistently one of the
fastest growing sectors of the food system
as a result.
And even more exciting trend is that
meat and dairy companies are actually
starting to jump on board. So
even Tyson chicken, their CEO,
the CEO of Tyson chicken said that plant
based protein is the way of the future.
And dairy companies are also investing
in plant based dairy. So Dannon Yogurt,
the parent company that makes Dannon
bought white wave, which makes silk,
so I'm milk and almond milk and they're
shifting a lot of their marketing budget
away from marketing dairy foods
towards marketing plant based foods.
So we see this very positive feedback
cycle where the more that we vote with our
dollars and we buy these products,
the more appealing that food sector
becomes to businesses. They invest in it,
then those products are more
widely available, they're cheaper,
they're more accessible. And so more
and more people start buying them.
And as we've seen,
especially with products like almond milk,
then they start to take up a larger and
larger market share. And as a result,
there are fewer animals bred
and killed for food every year.
And so oftentimes people say,
but I'm just one person.
What difference do my
food traces really make?
But we really can't have a very
direct impact on this industry.
And especially at a time when federal
policy is increasingly frustrating and
alarming.
You know,
there's zero chance of federal action
on climate change within these next few
years.
So this is even more important that we
can really directly impact this industry,
have a real impact on climate change
through our daily food choices.
And it's really never been easier or
tastier to eat these plant based foods.
So I'm guardian products are probably
my favorite. They have these great guy,
I'm crispy tenders and they're actually
owned by the company that makes hungry
man dinners.
So again,
we see these meat companies starting
to invest in plant based products. Um,
almond milk is available
every supermarket.
Ben and Jerry's now has seven flavors
of almond milk based ice cream.
So we see, again, it's,
it's a growing trend,
which is great for all of us because
it makes it so easy to do. And again,
you know,
you don't have to be 100% vegetarian to
order a veggie burger or Veggie burrito.
You don't have to be totally Vegan all
the time to put almond milk in your
cereal instead of cow milk. It's not
about being all or nothing, you know,
a hundred percent perfect.
It's about looking at the impacts of our
food choices and deciding what we our
money to support.
And the other good news is that again,
this really has a direct impact.
So supply and demand applies.
Demand has been going down since 2007
demand has dropped and as a result there
are 400 million fewer animals bred and
killed for food now than there were back
in 2007 as a direct result of people like
you and me deciding to eat less meat.
So remember that every time you
decide not to eat an animal product,
you are taking action against one of
the most destructive industries on the
planet.
Yeah,
we'd love to get your
feedback on the presentation.
So just a quick survey and if you'd
like to sign up for our mailing list,
we send out just once a month
newsletter with recipes,
national news about factory farming,
petitions to sign, things like that.
And we'll also send you some
recipes and some further resources,
but you can also fill this
out anonymously. Oh, so the,
is there, the question was,
is there a good place to find the sources
for the studies that I've cited or
more information?
Yeah,
so we have all of the citations for our
presentation available on our website
and we actually have a, um, a fortune,
I don't have any with me today,
but we have a new leaflet that's
focused on the environmental impacts and
there's a page with citations for
that also available on our website.
So those have all of the
original studies that were,
we're setting from the movie.
Cowspiracy is also a good resource
and they have a website with a lot of
information as well,
specifically about the environmental
studies for more information about food
sources and you know what to
eat, nutrition, all of that.
Choose vege.com is a really fantastic
resource. They've got meal plans,
tips for eating out all the
nutritional info that you need.
Yeah.
So the question is what's the relationship
between the animal products consumed
in the u s and what is
consumed around the world?
So I mean it's a pretty complicated
relationship. It depends on the industry,
but roughly 15% of products here exported.
So Americans do have no,
we have the second highest
meat consumption in the
world. We are actually, um,
pass by Australia,
but we do eat most of those products here.
Some of it is exported.
Um,
we do import some products as well
and a lot of these companies are now,
they started in the United States, but
they're now multinational corporations.
And actually Smithfield, which is
the largest pork producer, was um,
bought. Basically a majority stake
was bought by a Chinese company.
And so now we are starting to see an
increase in pork exports to China.
So now Americans are having to
deal with these environmental,
the environmental pollution and
these products are exported.
Another huge issue is Alfalfa feed.
Alfalfa is the most intensive crop in
terms of water and Saudi Arabia and other
countries are now, um, they're importing
Alfalfa from the United States.
So they're basically important water.
So,
and this is a huge problem because a
lot of that Alfalfa is grown in southern
California and Arizona and parts of the
country that are facing these droughts
and our water is actually being exported
to support the dairy industry in the
Middle East. And the US
is also, you know, we've,
we have set this example that
if you're well off, you know,
the lifestyle that we've,
that other people want to emulate as
their income grows is that, you know,
meat is an integral part of living well,
eating meat every day shows that you
are middle class or upper upper class.
And so there's a cultural impact as well.
Um,
and I'm hopeful that we can change that.
You know,
if we can show that the United States,
the saying actually now plant
based protein is the way to go.
This is a really exciting
way of the future.
Then hopefully countries that are starting
to ramp up their meat production will
shift to plant based protein as well.
Um,
I also have some resources here
for you that we can pass out.
So this is the guide to cruelty for
eating. It's got some great recipes,
nutritional info, and then if we
have any athletes in the room,
this is a compassionate athlete.
So there's this idea that um,
eating vegges feminine or it's
hard to get enough protein,
but this is a David Carter.
They call them the 300 pound Vegan.
He was an NFL player, actually played
for the Raiders and he's totally Vegan.
So good info in there as well.
Again,
where the factory farming
awareness coalition,
this is our website and we give
presentations. This is really what we do.
We're focused on grassroots education.
So if you know of any other, um, schools,
community groups,
businesses,
faith communities that might be interested
in learning more about this issue,
we're always happy to come out and
speak for free. All right. Thank you.
Thanks everybody for.